hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of modeling a masters I
believe that the fastest and most
effective way to grow your business is
to model the strategies that people who
have already done what you're trying to
do so today we're going to look at how
the fifteenth of 17 children who only
had two years of education went on to
become an entrepreneur and one of the
founding fathers of the United States of
America this is a story of Benjamin
Franklin and the top three lessons that
you can learn from his success Benjamin
Franklin did not come from a family of
prominence instead his family could only
afford to send him to two years of
grammar school and by the time he was 13
Franklin's father sent him off to
apprentice at his older brothers print
company here Franklin helped compose
pamphlets set up type Sal de beber on
the streets and perform other printing
related duties Franklin also began
writing columns under the pseudonym mrs.
silence do-good who he fabricated to be
a middle-aged Widow Dugan was an
immediate hit with her writings about
the problems and social conditions of
women but when James found out it was
actually his younger brother writing her
column he was furious as a result of
James's ensuing harassment and beatings
Franklin became a fugitive and ran away
from his family at the age of 17
Franklin tried his luck as a printer
both in New York and New Jersey but to
no avail he then moved to Philadelphia
where he did manage to find a job with a
printer but Franklin was unsatisfied
with his prospects there after a brief
stint at the printer shop in London
England Franklin returned to
Philadelphia in 1726 four years and much
borrowed money later
he had finally set up his own printing
house he began to publish a newspaper
called the Pennsylvania Gazette in which
he regularly gave himself space to
comment on the most pressing social
issues of the time he cultivated an
image of himself as an intellectual and
as a productive young man and his
writings with the beginning of what
would earn Franklin significant social
respect in 1748 Franklin officially
retired from the printing business
although he continued writing literature
and satirical essays throughout the rest
of his life he began to take a more full
role in public life becoming councilman
Justice of the Peace in Pennsylvania an
elected member of the assembly five
years later he was imported joint deputy
Postmaster General of North America and
several other posts in perhaps his most
well known feat Franklin began working
towards independence as part of the
committee of five the drafts of the
Declaration of Independence in 1787
after he had retired from public office
he attended a series of meetings that
would result in the United States
Constitution he became the only founding
father to sign all three of the
country's major founding documents the
Declaration of Independence the Treaty
of Paris and the US Constitution by
believing in himself and by teaching
himself Benjamin Franklin was able to go
from having almost no education to
becoming one of the most prominent men
in American history to help you rise to
prominence
here are three action items and you can
learn from Benjamin Franklin action item
number one always be learning if you
want your company to grow and become
successful you need to continue to grow
as an entrepreneur invest time and
resources into yourself and your team so
that you're always learning new skills
and pouring them back into your business
when you stop innovating and learning
your business will start to decline
despite having no formal education
Franklin understood its importance and
set out to satisfy his insatiable
appetite for knowledge on his own while
his father couldn't afford to send him
to school he nonetheless took the young
Franklin on walks various tradesmen
teaching him about their tools and
techniques his father also exposed him
to politics and current affairs having
himself been an active member of his
community by the age of eleven Franklin
had taught himself English French and
Italian and doggedly chased down any
literature he could find
Franklin's endless curiosity helped fuel
his business pursuits and his scientific
inquiries and propelled him to the
forefront of America's intellectual
community
according to Franklin it has been useful
to me having learned so much by it is as
to be able to do little jobs myself from
a child I was fond of reading and all
the little money that came into my hands
was ever laid out in books
genius without education is like silver
in the mind without continual growth and
progress such words as improvement
achievement and success have no meaning
action atom number two don't waste time
how much time do you waste every day are
you really doing the important things
that you need to in order to grow your
business
are you keeping busy with email Facebook
Twitter successful entrepreneurs don't
waste time when it's work time they work
focus your energies on the tasks it will
explode your business and ignore the
distractions in his autobiography
frankly McCall's is early days of owning
a printing shop where he was just
starting to get set up on his own and he
would often stay in the office working
past eleven o'clock at night if it meant
getting a task accomplished on time
Franklin would even say overnight to do
or redo it that was the case it is a
strong work ethic that Cary Franklin
through to the end of his career as one
of the most curious and ingenious of
America's earliest thinkers who has no
difficult task for Franklin to find
something to occupy his time with
industrious to the core
Franklin believes strongly and sees in a
moment and putting every minute to good
use however working hard was not only a
matter of profit and dollar signs of
Franklin it was a question of utilizing
what was given to you thus at the very
bottom line of Franklin success was a
hard work he put into every single goal
he decided to see through
according to Franklin employed like time
well if thou meanest to get leisure
sloth makes all things difficult but
industry all things easy he that rises
late must rot all day and shalt scarce
overtake his business at night thus I
loved life then do not squander time for
that's a stuff life is made of
action out of number three be kind to
one another
a lot of people think to be in business
you have to be cutthroat and ruthless
that couldn't be further from the truth
you can have tremendous success by being
kind to everyone involved with your
company and it's a lot more fun to
attend mechanical comm one of the first
things we look for in a new hire is is
he or she a nice person I hope you'll
consider doing the same even though
Franklin was wealthy enough to retire
comfortably at the age of 42 he
continued to pursue civic projects and
carry out neverland acts throughout the
rest of his life he staunchly believed
that the good life was achieved in
direct proportion to one's contribution
to society and thus from universities of
hospitals to fire houses Franklin
dedicated his resources to giving back
Franklin demonstrated that you could be
a successful entrepreneur and still have
compassion and care for the world around
you a precursor to today's movement
towards corporate social responsibility
Franklin proved to be once more a
pioneer in his field
according to Franklin he is ill clothed
that is Berra virtue advanced civil
purposes and at the same time support
the self-help efforts of individuals be
civil to all sociable too many familiar
with few friend to one and then me to
none if you would live long live well
for folly and wickedness shorten life
so remember always be learning waste no
time and be kind to one another to
finish up this video I wanted to share
when my favorite true stories about Ben
Franklin and some of his best quotes
Benjamin Franklin had no real opinions
on slavery until he went to England his
wife Deborah was not well educated and
had problems even writing to him a
pressure came in to visit in a grammar
school for black children while he was
stationed in London after visiting the
school Franklin found to his surprise
that black children which is as smart as
white children after coming Tintin he
changed his entire outlook on the way
slavery is being conducted in the United
States unknown to most people in America
Franklin is one of the first American
politicians to advocate the end of
slavery in the United States he had been
socially active most of his life even
creating one of the first fire
departments in Philadelphia during the
end of his life he spent a lot of time
speaking writing and public admonishing
other politicians that believed in
slavery he wanted to start schools for
black children and offer them the same
things white children had but in the end
all of his talk would be disregarded
however his beliefs would eventually
lead Abraham Lincoln to the same
realization
thank you for joining me for another
edition of modeling masters if you like
the video and you want to see more
please give it a thumbs up below and it
also love to hear you have to think if
you want to leave a comment underneath
the video and we'll see you on the next
episode
you